I call to order the December 15th 2023
meeting of the Health and Human Services
oversight committee would the clerk
please call the
role representative Pearson here
representative King here representative
Murphy representative McDonald
representative Weber here representative
Merchant here Senator
gray representative Edwards Senator
Rosenwald senator avard
five we have a quorum everyone except
Senator avard has already corresponded
with me saying that they wouldn't be
here for whatever reason or the other
since we have a quorum the next item is
to approve the draft minutes from the
November 17 2023 regular meeting Senator
second all in favor thank
you DHHS Commissioners update we will
happily listen to Deputy Commissioner
Marissa
hen
and Patricia
Tilly good afternoon um for the record
Marissa hen Deputy Commissioner and uh
commissioner Weaver sends her regards um
apologize that she can't be here um but
uh it looks like the main item for which
you were seeking updates um as a
committee was uh representative Edwards
request for information on the amamos
school health program and so director
Tilly is here to provide us that provide
us that and as we've done with other
recent Commissioners updates that's um
uh generally how we'll spend this time
today so good thanks sure well thank you
so much and again for the record my name
is Patricia Tilly I'm the director of
Public Health Services it's nice to be
here happy December um this is just a
very quick overview um as um the Deputy
Commissioner noted uh representative
Edwards has been very interested in our
school-based health project which has
been um in Manchester School District in
partnership with Amis Health Services uh
just to refresh your mind there's a and
there's a slide deck in front of you if
you want to get ahead and you know read
ahead um to refresh your mind back in
2021 as part of a number of funding
opportunities that came from the Centers
for Disease Control and prevention one
of them was around resources to help um
support the public health Workforce and
not only the public health Workforce
within the Department of Health and
Human Services but throughout the entire
State and one of the key areas that they
were interested in was school health um
Most states have lots of school health
clinics New Hampshire actually doesn't
we do not have a long history of that
and um but we use this as an opportunity
to support some efforts that we growing
um currently we do have um there are
probably two other areas in the state
that do school health in some way
Manchester is the area in which they
they have engaged in a much more robust
way to provide services and this
coincides with the youth Mental Health
crisis that we have been talking about
over and over at this commit at this
committee and so am SK took this
opportunity we put out an RFP um they
applied they were the only folks that
applied for the funds so we gave them
about a million dollars to get to work
to build some infrastructure within the
Manchester school districts to provide
both behavoral health services and
physical health services if you scoot
ahead in the slides a little bit on um
on slide uh I believe I they're not
numbered so where it says what was
accomplished we've been able to provide
almost 7,000 Behavioral Health visits
through this funding and that's through
um Amis being able to put behavioral
health professionals in person in
schools to provide those that Health
Care one of the things that repres
representative um Edwards has always
been concerned about this is parent
participation and parent um uh
permission to go through this process
you know this is just a reminder that we
built that into both our RFP process it
was an expectation going in that there
would be a robust expectations that
parents would be involved and have um be
able to determine what kind of what if
any kind of Health Services they
received um amamos took that in their
very um qualified very credible Health
Center they understand the importance of
parent participation and parent um uh
permission slips as it were and so they
worked with the school board and so the
school board approved the process the
health u center approved the process and
the Department of Health and Human
Services all approved that we've
received nothing but glowing feedback
from families that this is really
important to them it provides an
opportunity for them to get the services
they need while while they're kids in
school they don't have to go in pull
their kids out of school we all know
that learning time especially out of the
pandemic is so important and so again as
as a as a high reel almost 7,000
Behavioral Health visits about um
1,167 unique students were enrolled in
the services again not the entire School
District but really families that wanted
to be able to take part of that and
about 208 physical health services acute
care visit were also provided in this
time the money is going to run out we
knew this all along this was going to be
one-time money it was going to be in and
it was going to come out it um ends at
the end of this fiscal year but the good
news is is that with this investment we
were able to set up the services um
amamos was able to work out the Kinks in
terms of Medicaid billing and commercial
insurance billing and so this will be
sustainable long after our initial
investment in getting
you know the paperwork and getting the
actual space set up in the school those
investments will live longer um live
much longer than the actual investment
that we're going to make through public
health so I'm happy to take questions um
if there's
Tilly representative
King thank you Mr chairman uh it's just
a really quick question uh you mentioned
sustainability after the money runs out
um are you going to require more funding
how does how does that work the
sustaining part sure so the project was
built with the acknowledgement that
these funds their federal funds from CDC
were going to go away you know it was Co
money from Heaven it came out it was
going to be here and then it was going
to go and so our charge to amamos was
figure out how to do this um through
your own billing from both public
insurance and Commercial Insurance so
that you can can sustain this moving
forward and it's also within the um work
of a federally qualified Health Center
to provide other resource you know wrap
around resources as well the school has
also committed to make the space
available um at because they get the
benefit from it so it's a true
partnership in the
community representative
Weber so have I understood correctly
that what what you will have done after
this year is essentially
stood up a clinic a satellite Clinic
that happens to be operating in the
schools but is
funded in exactly the same way as amamos
gig's other operations that is correct
yes that's a much better way to to
you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair also thank
you for this wonderful report is there
something as scalable throughout the
state in other words taking what what we
learned in Manchester instead of
Reinventing the wheel taking that wheel
and applying it to other school
districts because I think according to
what we heard from represented Weber the
way you sort of framed it it's more of a
clinic based inside of a school system
and is that something we can duplicate
throughout the state know there are
other areas of the state that are
interested in it I know in straford
county in particular they've been toying
with this idea for a while through the
greater SE Coast um federally qualified
Health Center um they were not ready at
the time these funds were available to
jump on board interestingly Newport
School District up in Sullivan County
has been doing a version of this for
many years for well over a decade maybe
even almost close to two decades it sort
of grows and expands based on the
workforce that's available in that
Community but that's a partnership with
the Newport Health Center as part of New
London Hospital um so yes it's immensely
scalable we don't have particular
resources we use these Federal resources
right now to really stand it up and
again we were very pleased to be able to
do it in Manchester because the need is
so great and the scale is so great there
you know there certainly would be
challenges in smaller districts but I I
think this is a model that could could
state is that uh aspirational or are
there plans to try to make it go wider
it's aspirational at this point because
we don't have the resources to sort of
say here get going you know we had these
resources they had beginning and an end
date um we were thrilled that Manchester
was able to make it work but we are
always happy to partner with our other
health centers or other federally
qualified Health Centers we support them
in other ways through the division of
Public Health Services um and certainly
Amis is is very willing to share their
learning on how they make this work and
should funds become available from
whatever sources you got the model yes
and we would be happy to promote this
again if funds were were to be made
available if you know General funds were
to be made available we could do
that anyone else I have a question yes
Senator commissioner yes Senator
um and I I'm GNA wax poetic here a
little bit uh Dr Sherman and I former
Senator uh had a conversation in Health
and Human Services several years ago
about a particular program and he was
putting all these restrictions and I
says well that's something that the
oversight committee should know all
right but I have no way personally of
going in and saying okay all of the
requirements that are put upon you by
Statute are being taken care of okay um
I've been on this committee for two
three years whatever it is now and I
don't see that this committee has a way
of doing that either and and so um back
in my former days it would have been an
an internal audit to make sure that I
was doing the things I was supposed to
and I would like to either see that or
see a report of that uh done in health
and human services so that I know that
you and I are on the same page as to
requirements and actions yeah no thank
you so much for the the question um so
it's something that I think we want
to think about really thoughtfully but
what I and and there are other groups
who have come to us in a similar vein of
saying like joint fiscal committee has
said you know can you provide us some of
the basic statistics on your operating
activities or in this case you're asking
more around our areas of statutory
Authority so we definitely are in the
process of working on some more public
facing dashboards to provide that Bird's
eyee view um another thing that we
embarked on this year that um I believe
we presented here uh about nine months
ago is we worked on our first ever road
map as a department meant to outline our
um priorities as we fulfill um our
obligations the department and our um
statutory uh requirements as well as
some of the Strategic priorities around
Health and Human Services happening um
based on need here in the state and and
being seen nationally in some cases so
um we are looking to grow some of that
and make more transparent some of our
strategic planning as a department which
has never really been done before and I
think this could be an excellent body to
share that with I think given your
interest what I'm hearing in your
question is a desire not just for you to
be coming to us with topics but for us
to be reporting to you some of what's
going on some of what's succeeding some
of what what what is struggling does
that begin to answer some of what you're
asking about the way I would have termed
it you know in my past life is a
compliance audit okay is that here's the
list of the statutes you know in here
there is a go do or th th sh thou shal
so i' certainly you know I want to bring
it up today I'm certainly willing to
work with your your Prime legal counsel
there in the back uh I would like it put
on as an agenda item for continuing
meetings uh so that we can talk about it
but I know and I'm going to go to
fishing game okay fishing game had a
requirement to do
okay they ignored it they ignored it
they ignored it they ignored it okay how
do I make sure that that's not happening
in other departments well one way in
this one is I am on the oversight
committee and I want to know how you
guys are ensuring
compliance so we'll leave it at that for
right now they'll give us a whole month
to talk about it and figure out what we
want to do it's going to be an agenda
item I've got the chairs you know head
shaken up and down
and Mr Williams Esquire is more than
happy I'm sure to come see me and talk
about what we can and cannot do yeah no
thank you for the idea we will um look
forward to brainstorming with uh with Mr
Williams also with our um director uh of
the division for program quality and
integrity I mean as you know we do a
tremendous amount to demonstrate that we
are we are fulfilling our obligations to
a number of different bodies including
our federal authorities who um fund a
significant amount of this through
Medicaid and other channels so I
appreciate your interest in wanting to
in in in fact in giving us an
opportunity to share the ways in which
we're meeting those obligations and to
invite questions about areas of our work
since it is very broad um that may not
naturally come up on the agenda
otherwise so let's all put our heads
together and see what we can come up
with representative Weber
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
point out that in this life we do have
um as an ongoing operation uh the
opportunity to ask for performance
Audits and obviously a performance audit
of the entire department is well outside
the scope of anything any of us can
possibly manage but if there are I
believe the senator made a reference to
a specific program so if there was a
specific programmer parameters that you
were concerned about that's exactly what
the purpose of a performance audit is is
to take the statutory directives and
ensure that they are being followed and
if not why not and there's an in-depth
exploration of um what might what needs
to change what might change what might
be an unreasonable expectation but it's
a really good start for a very thorough
conversation and I
highly recommend it and I sit on that
committee so let me
know representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair following up on the Senator's
comments about the issue of
compliance being inste of uh new
individual in this committee what would
be helpful to me is understanding what
are the things we're looking to be
compliant to because I don't really
understand what statutory requirements
are out there that the department has to
basically comply too so before we get
into the compliance audit be helpful for
myself anyways to understand what are
the things we should be thinking about
looking at and going back to our
meetings and saying are we talking about
the statutory requirements that the
department has to fulfill to be
compliant with
whatever Mr chair just representative
Weber I can't know what particular
compliances Senator gray has in mind but
um basically the compliance that is
looked at in a performance audit is the
statutory requirements of Any Given
program so they're going to be very
different for every single program
they're not you know uh it's it's not
one thing but um they can be looked at
there there can also be discussions
directly but I I just wanted to make it
clear that they
are the compliance that they look at as
opposed to whatever it is that Senator
gray is looking for is taken directly
from the statute that applies to
whatever program you're looking at do
you just read the statute followup thank
you and thank you for them represent
Weber I'm not looking per se
for how they being compant to whatever
it is we're talking about compliance too
but what are the list of the programs
that require some sort of compliance
because it's a large where do I find
that
list I'm pretty sure when I became
Deputy Commissioner there are these big
books on my shelf that were handed to me
in their Health and Human Services
statute for so and they're they're great
paper weights and they're undoubtedly
contain also really important
information I think that our challenge
throughout this is going to be how to
make it useful and how to make it I mean
without again with a spirit and a
commitment toward full
transparency um our responsibilities and
our our portfolio if you will is so is
is really quite vast especially when
compared to other departments in the
state and so I think what I appreciate
about the challenge you're giving us
collectively here is how do we how do we
provide an overview of what the
department does so that you can zero in
on those areas of interest and so that
we can complete Our obligation to you of
of providing information justification
identifying our strengths and our
weaknesses um and so I think I think
it's a it's a CH all but I think there
have to be ways that we can make we can
take those books and turn it into both a
um a road map for what I'm sorry reusing
the ro road map but essentially we
should be able to describe what we do to
you uh and just as we do every budget
season to the various budget committees
we should be able to um provide
opportunities to be ask questions but we
also don't want it this to turn into a
10-hour meeting of going through giant
volumes of hard cover um texts I think
useful
good we'll keep the dialogue going on
that thank you so much thank you and
speaking of councilor Williams will you
introduce your special new friends here
point now the hardest part about
testifying before committee
is what that turn the on clearly and tur
the mic on thank you it's nice to be
back here again this year I'm a little
less nervous than I was last year um and
I remember bringing a copy of the thank
you note that Michaela who will
introduce herself in a moment sent to me
on behalf of the tuition waiver program
this year I was able to get her to
appear before you in person so my name
is Beth me I am an employee of
Department of Health and Human Services
as a youth engagement
specialist and part of my position is
oversight of the tuition waiver
program it's um the benefit of the
program is
invaluable um it has assisted youth all
over the state to attend our Comm
community colleges and the University of
New Hampshire
system
colleges um a significant positive
change to the tuition waiver program
occurred July 1st with the passage of a
house bill where our youth-driven work
we came to the State House on a number
of occasions this past fall or a year
ago um these changes included increasing
the number of waiver per system from 15
to
35 it also moved the age limitation for
application from 23 to 26 because not
all
youth have a prescribed way of attending
school um it also incl was more
inclusive for um dcyf care for
guardianship or who were placed with a
relative out of state to be eligible for
the
year we had an unprecedented 65
certified applicants apply for the
tuition
waiver for various reasons 52 of them
followed through and are in in the
university and Community College system
now um and that was well over the 49
applicants from last year and the 48
from
2022 so it really has shown a big
expansion which is
exciting um 24 waiver slots were awarded
from the University system of New
Hampshire 10 of them to returning
students and uh 28 to the community
college system 10 of them also returning
students so we're starting to see youth
graduate and become certified in the
areas of study that they're interested
in um
so I guess I'll introduce
Michaela hi um my name is michaa Willie
um I am a sophomore in college and this
is my second year um receiving the
tuition waiver so my mom adopted me and
she is a single mother on a teacher
salary so she offered to help me pay for
college but I didn't want to put that
burden on her so I went to nhti and the
tuition waiver really helped I wanted to
do dental hygiene which is expensive to
buy all of your equipment so that would
have been relief um but I actually
decided that I wanted to change to
occupational therapy um and I really
would not have considered that if it
wasn't for the tuition waiver because
they don't have that at nhci so I had to
switch to un which is a big Financial
jump from nhg so I was thankful to
receive it again and it has allowed me
to apply and get into the Occupational
Therapy Program and I am really excited
to pursue that and it wouldn't have been
waiver represent representative
Weber I just wanted to say as as a
member of this body and a member of the
Health and Human Services thank you for
choosing to go into the healthc care
field because we really need you and
congratulations on that thank
you anyone else in the
committee well keep us up to date on
this and thank you so much both for
coming thank you thank you very much and
thank you for all you do for the
citizens of New Hampshire we're in it
money
I've asked uh Mr Henry Lipman our
Medicaid director to come to this
meeting and give us an update on
whatever he wants to but especially the
Medicaid dental and I see that um Delta
dentl gave somebody a half a million
dollars it it wasn't me so I'm just
wondering um if you know what it goes to
does some of it or all of it go to the
dental uh program that we're doing or
what welcome
thank you uh for the record Henry lman
the state's Medicaid director the I
think the donation you're talking about
went to the federally qualified Health
Center in Manchester um as a general
donation but that program does have
dental with it and so indirectly will'll
be supporting it um all the more since
she's no longer going to be a dental
hygienist yes that's right um and I
think they've also um I don't think it's
maybe made it to public uh as widely
publicly known but I think they also
helped the eMusic Health Center recently
as well um and um you know I think that
they're making a good effort to to uh
help build out the network it's we still
have work to do um I know there was an
article recently in the New Hampshire
bulletin about uh you know for the
developmentally disabled in terms of
expanding the number of dentists who um
but I think the good news there is The
Advocates um are working with us and
trying to help us um and trying to um
reach and get additional dentist to
participate um we I think have seen um
uh the month of uh our latest statistics
um an increasing number of individuals
who think over 3,000 last month that had
Dental claims um and so it continues to
build not
we still have more to to to do there but
I think if you look at what had to be
done in terms of the time to stand up
the program get all the waivers in place
um and and you know basically build out
a network we're really pretty young in
the life of of the dental program um and
um I think that also rates have been in
the news a little bit I do want to make
sure people are aware that the adult
Dental rates
um when the legislature approved the
appropriation allowed us to almost
double what they were historically and
um Delta Dental has also added to it in
certain select procedures where they
feel like they need to help build the
network out um further at you know at
their expense if you will um and I I'll
working on getting you some statistics
on that in terms of how our Medicaid
Program compares to others as a
percentage of commercial so I think I
have a a report uh that will suggest
that we're sort of on the upper end in
terms of Medicaid programs now with with
that change we also I know Children's
dental program is not part of um the
Delta program at this point but also
through um hb2 we're able to bring the
Children's Dental rates so that they're
equal which um was starting to become a
problem since they weren't so that's
been implemented um we're still using a
mobile Dental um van to help build out
the the network so I'll stop there and
see if there are any
dle have you in your opinion pretty much
got to the number of participating
dentists you think you're going to get
to or are you getting one or two a
little bit at a time now a little bit at
a time now what I hope to be able to
demonstrate through the the program that
you know if you kind of think about
technology they're early adopters and
then people come along the line I think
we have the early adopters pretty well
captured and I think we need to work our
way up towards um people who may wait a
while to make sure that the program's
working as intended and also Delta
Dental had also provided sign on bonuses
for quite a long time in terms of just
for signing up they paid $1,000 for for
someone to join and I also want to say
if if you hear of people that um are in
a dental distress situation Dr Finny um
and the dental director at Delta Dental
can help get access if there's a certain
circumstance where you know someone's
having a real Dental problem um you know
I know even in the private dental world
it's hard to get even you know basic
teeth cleaning um you know as fast as
you'd like sometimes so um we working at
it and you know I heard earlier about
the the funding that uh helped that
individual my understanding there's some
more money coming into play for for
recruitment remind me about dental Vans
going to remote
places so um we have a company that
through Delta Dental and denta quest
which is their subcontractor um where
they come in with a complete um
operatory if you will um with with a
dentist and they've been going to a
communities um where there have been um
you know shortage of dentists relatively
they've gone to you know up to Berlin
they've gone up to Laconia they've gone
um they're planning to be on the up in
the Claremont area they've been that
one's taking a little while to find a
place where they can site it because
it's a pretty big big vehicle
um but we're probably getting two or
three days a month and then we come back
after so many weeks if there's followup
care so that can be done as well how
relatively easy or difficult is it for a
dentist and or a hygienist to work off
of other tools like tools that are in a
van as opposed to their office so they
actually bring the whole team and so
that's it's a it's a complete dental
practice if you will that's that's
portable good
anyone thank you for the update sure um
and just the other thing I'd share in
terms of the
redetermination efforts um you know
we're we're fairly much I think we're
within a couple percent of or hundreds
of people at this point of completing
the process of redetermining
people um the last few months in terms
of both the people about there were 100
about almost 104,000 people that we
needed to
who hadn't because of the uh pandemic um
and and the regular renewals now that um
the last three months have seen the
highest rate of retention um in the the
the regular renewals last month we had
89 and a half% of the people retain uh
coverage we're still doing a lot of
Outreach uh particularly in the
vulnerable areas we've slowed down to
make sure that people who are like Home
and Community Based service oriented um
long-term care that we've given them an
extra 60 days to to help complete their
redeterminations we've um working with
the CFI case managers um trying to give
them more information so that they can
help people this has been the most
challenging group to work with because
they not only have to provide income
information but they often have to
provide information about assets and and
get bank account information and they
may not have done that for the last
three and a half years and um then there
are also people who've aged out of the
Medicaid Program and trying to help them
get into Medicare and and signed up for
the right things there um but um you
know I'm I'm pleased with the progress
that we've made and and I think we'll be
the better for it uh going forward in
terms of what we've learned um by having
to manage this and um you know if you
hear of someone that's having a
challenge I want to hear about it and um
we'll we'll try to do what we can to
help
them thank you thank you so much welcome
me and now the chair recognizes the New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging to
report and the chair would like to
recognize um former representative
paully Campion and present
representative Charles McMahon is part
of this group welcome back and welcome
over
and on
this right okay did I miss anybody
else good thank you the commission is
well represented today um hello my name
is Rebecca Sky I'm currently serving as
the executive director for the state
Commission on Aging our our chair
current chair of the commission suruka
sitting next to me I'm going to give her
a um a a sec in a little bit I'll give
her a chance to introduce herself more
thoroughly we do have a few other
commission members um in the room we
have um Wendy Alman who represents
Department of Health and Human Services
on the commission we have Sue uh Sue
buckton who is the New Hampshire's uh
long-term Caren budsman um who is also
on the commission um I think you named
the other folks oh in addition we are
very grateful for representative Weber
and her her deep interest and engagement
in in the commission's work it's been
fabulous to have her um okay so uh just
to want to give a just a very brief
introduction to the commission the
commission was established during the
2019 legislative session our key charge
is to advise the governor and
legislature on issues related to aging
we study areas of public policy that
impact all of us as we age and we
produce an annual report with our
findings um this is just one of the many
ways that we carry out our charge we Al
also have a fabulous newsletter called
Aging matters that Finds Its way into
your legislative uh uh email inboxes um
it is put together by it is edited by a
volunteer um other residents in New
Hampshire who find Value in it also
receive it it's really chalk full with
great information and perspectives on
Aging here in in New Hampshire
um so in our in my brief time uh today
um what I'd like to do is I'm going to
just give a um an overview for how this
report is organized um that you have
before you and Sue um is going to dive
into a little bit more of the content
the priorities that the Commission on
Aging has identified for New
Hampshire so if you'd like to go along
with me if you turn to page
three you'll see our vision mission and
values the in inaugural set of
commission members uh determined what
these were and set the path for us going
forward Bo um at the bottom you have the
list of the commission members who put
the work into developing this report and
and who approved the report in November
we've since had some transition to some
commission
members if you turn to the next page
page four um you'll see um a list of the
commission activities over the previous
year and then page five begins to dive
into the priorities the commission has
identified for New Hampshire three of
the four of them are the same as the
previous year
uh strengthen systems of care for
healthy aging grow the Direct Care
Workforce Advance age-friendly policy
systems and environments and the new one
for this year is a call for the
development of a multi- sector plan for
Aging in New
Hampshire if you turn to the next page
you begin to see how um we dive into
each of these priorities um we start
with a very brief description of what
the priority recommendation is then we
dive into the progress on on that
particular recommendation over uh that
was made in the legislature of the
previous year you'll see you'll see the
summary of the wonderful work that you
did uh and then what follows is the list
of recommendations for next steps that
the commission has identified for New
Hampshire so then jumping to the back of
the report page it's the page
21 um it looks like this um you'll see a
demographic snapshot of of new Hampshire
looking at at older adult
populations um New Hampshire is the
second oldest state in the Union by
median age over 27% of the state's
population in 2020 is aged 60 and older
one in two households in New Hampshire
has one or more persons aged 60 and
older where New Hampshire is now is
where many other states in the union
expect to be in 2035 we really are on
the The Cutting Edge of the
transformational demographic
shift if you look down to the middle of
the page you can see um where older
adults live here in New Hampshire um
Carol County uh has the greatest density
of older
adults per capita and then if you look
on the right you can see um what we all
would expect that Hillsboro County um
has the lar largest raw numbers of older
adults and then at the bottom of the
page is what I think um you as
legislators might be most interested in
it shows
um it provides a
um a graph of anticipated Trends the
numbers rise for ages 65 plus through
2050 it's really that graph that drives
um what we need to plan for and why the
commission was
created and if you turn to the second to
the last page you'll see a letter from
governor Nunu uh um offering support for
the development of um a multi- sector
plan for aging it's it's he has seen
that uh that Trend graphed on the
previous
page um and then the last page of the
report is a timeline shared by the
Department of Health and Human Services
back in August on for the implementation
of the system of care for healthy aging
legislation that was passed last session
uh and now at this point I'm going to
turn the mic over to um the commission
chair Su Ruka who will introduce herself
and provide a little a little bit of a
deeper dive into some of the um
priorities that are listed in this plan
and thank you thank you Rebecca for that
ni really nice overview and thank you
for having us here today um we really
appreciate it I'm Sue rer and I'm the
chair of the commission I live in the
Mount Washington Valley I've a nurse by
background and I have worked in the
field of Aging for many years before I
became an older adult myself I was
working in the field of Aging um and I'm
very passionate about it and committed
to being sure that we deliver we have
people who are living in New Hampshire
have the best quality of life we can
they can possibly have no matter what
age um when I Was preparing for this um
presentation I was looking through our
the one of the values that jumped out at
me and in the beginning of the report
you see that we have our values is
forward thinking and I think that's the
we are right now and it's also
modernizing aging we really do need to
switch our view of how we view older
adults
um and how we view aging um or we're not
going to be successful as Rebecca gave
you all the statistics and we are we are
leading the country in terms of figuring
out what to how to provide quality of
life for people who are as they age um
we if we don't we can continue the same
way but if we don't we're not going to
have the resources to not only provide
care but neither are we using the value
and wisdom of older adults and many of
us in this room can prove that we're
very vibrant and active and strong and
contribute a lot to the um to the
Forward Thinking in New Hampshire to the
economy um to many things so we need to
capitalize on the on the value of older
adults and not always seen it as a
liability which a lot of times is how it
comes across yes we are going to have to
be providing more care and more and it
may be more costly but there's also a
value on wisdom we have to figure out
how to better use that um um so we have
um as Rebecca said we have four
priorities now three are the same as
they were in the past um and then the
fourth one uh I'm not going to go into a
lot of detail under the accomplishments
it is in the report and there's really a
lot of work that it's been done by um
the task force by the commission by
other members and by many of you because
many of you were the ones involved with
create crafting and um passing
legislation that move things forward um
and there been a lot done this year um
the report also has details that will
take you to links to give you even more
information and we're also a resource
we're always here so feel free to if
there's more information that you want
to know about something you can reach
out to us um the first priority
strengthening the system of care um I
just want to bring your attention to the
graphs on page seven um and that's
showing that Phil um scull slon did
these um from the policy Institute it
shows the Appropriations for Medicaid um
from 2011 and Beyond not saying that
2011 was correct but it was a start and
the trend is interesting um when you
look at it most of the investment has
been in facility based care and yet we
know people want to be at home and we
also know that home care and adult day
centers are less costly options for
people that they can remain at home
longer um so but that was a the
interesting tend that we've invested
more facility based care not to say that
facility based care is needed for some
people and I ran a a nursing home for
quite a few years as well so it's
appropriate for some people but
sometimes it's premature admission or
it's unnecessary for some people so we
need to balance it out and really look
at home and Community Based care which
is where people want to be and I think
the pandemic also disproved how much
people want to be at home
um just highlighting a few of the
accomplishments um and many of you were
involved with this increasing the
payment to providers for Medicaid for
Home and Community Based care for the
long-term care aspects of um Home Care
um was was great this year and there
were a few agencies um on the verge of
closing if they hadn't got some increase
in payment um excuse
me and also sorry also um streamlining
the application process for Medicaid and
making it easier for families it was a
burden for families to be pulling all
that and cutting it to a three-year look
back unless there's an issue and a few
of the other things um really make
making it easier for people to be able
to get on Medicaid and also be able to
get the Home and Community Based
Services quicker rather than just
facility based care um Page 6 to8 goes
through the accomplishments that we've
we've done just a few other noteworthy
ones where increased funding for Meals
on Wheels which is sometimes the um the
main contact that somebody living at
home who is socially isolated has with
Meals on Wheels and with the cost of
food going up um some there was some
increased funding for that and also some
work on housing um the I want to just
focus on a little bit on the next steps
which start on page nine um now that the
foundation's in place um we really want
to over we need we need your assistance
in overseeing the robust implementation
of it um and also to continue to develop
the infrastructure um the infrastructure
so but there there's a lot of um things
that was set in motion this year and the
implementation of that will be really
important um we also uh looking at like
home modification programs so that
people can stay at home um is another
important um priority um determining the
needs of caregivers uh really doing a
good assessment getting people hooked up
with services and supports early on so
they can make better decisions about
what they want um and then piloting some
models that have been tested and have
been success uccessful we've looked at
several and there were SE there were
quite a few identified in the report um
and some models that that were
successful so people can remain in the
community of choice um and have the
support and services they need for a
longer period of time um and then the
Direct Care Workforce um which leads us
into the next priority so everybody's
focusing on uh Workforce because
Workforce is a problem across the entire
country and and then New Hampshire is
well um but we focused on the commission
more on the direct for work force those
that are actually providing care to
older adults um living at home or in
facilities um if you just point you to
the graph on page 10 and it shows the
decline from 2022 to 2023 in
particularly lnas and registered nurses
um the licensed nursing assistants and
registered nurses so we have less in the
field now and we're going to need about
24,000 more direct care workers by 2028
so that is definitely heading Us in the
wrong
direction
um Pages 11 through 13 go through more
step more on what the work that's been
done over this last year and there been
tremendous accomplishments and and as I
said many of you are familiar with it
and you've been involved in making sure
that it happened um if I look for next
steps um you know when we're talking
talk about Direct Care Workforce access
to affordable housing child care and
transportation are some of the major
barriers why our direct um care
Workforce is low um living on Lower
wages they can't afford housing I live
in the Mount Washington Valley you know
a tourist area and you can't find
housing for a family for anything less
than 2,000 a month and you know that's
reasonable if it can find that so um
housing is is
the excuse me housing is really the
underlying root problem of many many
things and the most difficult one to
really um grasp but there are there are
some um pilot programs and some other
things things like home share and other
stuff that are being done that we could
really investigate and invest and invest
in more um tuition assistance and
support for training and advancement and
I was wonderful having the group that
presented ahead of us um because that's
a perfect example and I can tell you
occupational therapists for homing
Community Based care they can be amazing
to be able to keep people in their homes
um and more independent but um but
training and reimbursement uh there's
several programs that have been piloted
and started and again in the um on page
12 there's links to all of them um some
of them they were just showing some some
success and funding ran out so they
stopped but they could be picked up
again and invested in in a little bit um
um more um invested in more and then be
able to um um have more of a direct ha
Workforce sorry um and then um also um
some states have invested in building a
um a healthcare Workforce in investment
and Innovation um fund so it's another
way of looking at what would be
different options to really improve your
direct a
Workforce um another option another
thing is removing barriers to licensing
um but not eliminating the license um
because and I know that sounds like a
catch 22 we want more of a Workforce but
we want we don't you know we talk about
licensing barriers however we have a
much more fragile um vulnerable
population people living longer with
more complex illnesses um and so you
have to balance out the need for the
volume of workers with with the safety
and making sure there's good oversight
for them so I you know not recommending
plus the licensed nursing assistants
themselves do not want the license
removed they feel that's a that's an
achievement they made and they're proud
of it and it helps keep them in that
Workforce and in that
field um the next um priority is um
ageef friendly policy systems and
environments I'm going to go through
this one quickly because I do want to
give us time for questions at the end um
not and I'm going through it quickly not
because it's not as important but we've
it crosses so many sectors um when I
look at that you know the things that
jumped out at me you know we list the
accomplishments but reducing agism agism
is something that we're it's Insidious
it's arried in many many aspects in our
language and our policies and our
practices um and that is even when we
talk about Direct Care Workforce if
we're not valuing older adults and we
allow agism people aren't going to go
into the field we can make many many
things they have many people have um PE
workers have many options to go into why
are they going to choose Healthcare
which is one of the more difficult ones
and the direct here direct here which is
very which is physically tiring and um
and and a difficult profession unless we
really promote the value of older adults
and what they're doing um in the
workfield to um make life better for
people so I think agism to me we first
create we have to create greater
awareness and we have to do everything
we can to reduce agism um creating
age-friendly workplaces um rewarding
employees who um create them and um
modernize workplaces research the
research does show that a multi-age team
um is more productive but the research
also shows that age discrimin mination
is pretty high
um and um age friendly housing age ready
housing is important um as well so that
homes people can have their homes
modified or that they're that we create
more housing that's age friendly um and
there looking at other piloting models
of care in alternative settings is a
great option and there been there's a
lot of Pilots out there that have been
successful um investing in technology um
and that's becomes even more and more
important um Broadband in in rural areas
and broadbanded areas where people don't
have it that's really important and I
know there's work being done on that but
also the other types of technology that
can keep keep people in their homes I
was we did a conference recently and I
did not even realize this technology
that can tell somebody's Fallen this
technology that can you can use your
lecture and your sir to be able to um
put prompts and reminders and check in
and and so in a an adult child living a
little more distantly can you know check
in on a parent and make sure that
they're they're okay and and they can
have there is going to be an increase in
memory loss and dementia diagnosis so
people can have prompts that allow them
to be independent and stay at home
longer excuse me um so those are um
those are things that we should be
investing in um Civic engagement is
another one and I'm not going to go into
details on that but um making it easier
for older adults to participate in
things you know more virtual options um
you know quorums for um meetings that
can be virtual and in person so that
people AR don't have the burden of
traveling and addressing social
isol isolation excuse me and finally I
just want to talk briefly a little bit
about the multi sector plan which is the
fourth priority and that was a new one
for this year um people are living
longer and healthier lives um that's
called you know the long longevity
economy um we have more years of
disability Free Living so we have those
years to capitalize on and have older
adults that can be productive in the
workforce you know by creating you know
um age-friendly Health Systems as I said
before um and making changes in
scheduling and policies so then older
adults are able to work longer bringing
older adults back into the workforce
they they were good you know a lot of
people can't really retire so if we can
make it easier and people can work U
maybe less hours um and making it easier
for older adults to stay in the
workforce um anyhow the um so that the
reasons around going back to the multis
sector plan there's a national movement
to really create an multi sector plans
it's it's going on in many states it's
not supposed to be a book that you
develop and put on the Shelf um it
should build on existing plans we have a
lot of plans we have the state plan on
Aging we have a state mental health plan
we have a state Transportation plan and
those are all great and what a multi
sector plan would be pulling them all
together because sometimes they're a bit
siloed and if we can pull them together
and have them um more cohesive and
everybody's knowing what's going on in
each of them we can we can really plan
for our state to be in better
shape um also Forward Thinking to be
sure that we're not only surviving but
thriving the multi- sector plan is
usually a 10-year plan and sometimes
that's like well that's too long but we
want to it should be built so that
you're surviving and thriving through
whatever changes in politics whatever
changes in um you know who's in the
legislation who's in the governor's
office it survives that because it's a
bipartisan plan that's agreed on that
we're looking for the future of the
state
um on page 19 I'm just going to direct
you to there's five key elements in an
Alti sector plan um decisive leadership
it should be rational with data
comprehensive have stakeholders who are
bought into it and have accountability
built in it's usually a partnership with
public and
private we've been invited to be part of
a multi-state um learning collaborative
um Rebecca and Matha McLoud recently
went to California um for part of the um
the um training part the training
program but um it's a it's a
collaboration program some states are
ahead of us some states are are further
behind but it's an opportunity we have
to have some resource so we're not
trying to do it on on our own and making
it more a more efficient process um the
most successful ones have an executive
order from the governor and as Rebecca
said we already have a letter of support
um and we would be going after once we
have some more information and executive
water but it also requires the act of
participation by legislators um in
supporting the plan um by all of you and
what your constituents are telling you
um to bring be able to bring that
forward and then have it be um sent to
the commission and then you know we help
pull out that information together but
your your support in my it won't be
successful without the legislative
support we're going to need to uh wrap
it up now would you take any questions
from the committee
uh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for the wonderful report it's uh
nice to hear about what we're doing here
in New Hampshire for
thei one of the things that I see
happening at least in my neck of the
woods and talking to
constituents is housing and aging in
place is part of it but a lot of times
the house they reside in today as they
age is something sometimes a challenge
because they have to encounter stairs
they go up to the bedrooms with the
bathrooms are too small and so forth is
there any thought anywhere of trying to
work with seniors to
create affordable housing for the
elderly I think it does a couple things
one is it provides them the social part
it provides them with housing and so
forth that would help them to live
longer and and be free if you will but
at the same time if they vacate their
home their today that's another home
that goes on the market so it's a double
win because it's a place they can go to
to solve some of their problems I know
we have Contin care retirement
communities but most people can't afford
it so where's the hybrid where's the
compromise there to try to find ways to
help our elderly live in housing that's
something they can afford at the same
time manage B upon their disabilities
and try to free up the market and saying
well all of a sudden we have an
additional house on the market
uh that's an excellent question um the
state is doing a lot of investment into
housing invest NH for example um I think
we have to think about housing
holistically and that any new housing
that gets built needs to be age ready
which means uh a step-free entry and a
bath and a bedroom on the first floor
the US Census just came out with report
New England of course has the oldest
housing housing stock in the country and
so if we if we don't just think about
okay we're building houses for elderly
more this is how we want to build
housing here here in New Hampshire and
it really serves all populations better
um I think that's a that's the approach
we need to
take um so so oh go ahead go ahead no I
I just was just adding you know our key
ask for for uh for us legislators is is
to join our call for the development
development of this multisector plan and
to engage in its creation because the
commission that was created we can go
off and have all these great ideas but
if if there we need ideas that that
policy makers like yourself um know will
work for New Hampshire and are willing
to implement um and and um and we need
and so we need everybody's help in
creating it so that's why we're we're
calling for this multis sector plan and
and for you know to engage in a process
that will engage you in its
creation any other
questions seeing none thank you and
thank everyone from this group for
coming today and we'll be hearing more
from you I know okay thank you so much
and um we a phone call away or an email
thank
you and there are a lot of us on the
everywhere the chair now recognizes
healthc care acquired infections report
update Katrina Hansen administrat
DHHS good afternoon uh committee members
and chairman thank you for having me
here today for the record my name is
Katrina Hansen I oversee infectious
disease surveillance within the division
of Public Health Services um within the
Bureau of Infectious Disease
Control I am here today to provide an
update on the healthcare Associated
infections program but I'm going to use
the term Hai going forward it's a
mouthful um this is a legislatively
creative program within the division of
Public Health Services so today I'm
presenting four reports but I will try
to be brief as much as I can um for is a
Friday afternoon we have just released
or plan to release next week and publish
online the 14th report of the occurrence
of these infections in hospital
hospitals the 11th report in Ambulatory
Surgery centers the first report in
dialysis centers and the sixth report of
influenza vaccination among Health Care
Personnel in long-term care settings uh
we have also distributed um these
reports to you in highlight and your
folders um we have our letter to health
and human services along with some
talking points and then only the
executive summary of each report in your
packets because they're very long
reports we'll make sure to send those
out in the final updated link uh but
those have been sent to you but I just
for brevity and to save resources we
kept it brief this is the 10th year over
10 years we've been reporting on these
um so I will really highlight certain
components of each report and then I
also have a disclaimer that there are
many acronyms and complex terms but I
will also introduce both um in the
beginning for an initial Clarity for
Hospital reports hospitals are required
to report central line bloodstream
infections and catheter Associated urine
tract infections in intensive care units
and surgical site infections following
certain and heart colon knee and
abdominal hysterctomy surgeries
hospitals are also required to report
Healthcare Personnel influenza
vaccination rates overall New Hampshire
observed significantly fewer infections
than predicted based on National Data
overall 129 infections were reported by
hospitals for
2021 uh which is 68.89% fewer than
predicted there are significant fewer
infections for Ur urin tract infections
and surgical sight infections overall
when compared to national data
compliance with measures that put that
are put in place to protect patients was
also high so for example Healthcare
vaccination coverage in hospitals was
90.4% which means the healthy people
2020 goal of 90% And is an increase from
the prior prior year there were a total
of 802 clas defal or C infections
reported however program was unable to
compare New Hampshire data to National
Data and provide risk adjusted rates due
to technical challenges with the system
outside of our program control however
our staff are actively working to
resolve that in those issues so data can
be included in future iterations in
addition it was brought to our attention
earlier today that there was a minor
transcription error on page 72 of our
report we'll be sure to fix that before
our
publication for Ambulatory Surgery
centers 12 centers reported surgical
site infections following breast hernia
and open reduction of fracture
procedures 15 facilities did not report
influenza vaccination data two
facilities did not report surgical site
infections data and facilities did not
report surgical antimicrobial
prophylaxis zero infections were
reported by ant by Ambulatory Surgery
centers for 2022 which is actually
considered lower than National Data and
since the beginning of this reporting
ASCS have reported very few to zero
surgical site
infections compliance with measures put
in place for patients was also high in
Outpatient Surgical centers uh influenza
vaccination rate was 87.7% a slight
decreas from the prior year but still
close to to 90% healthy people 2020 goal
adherence of surgical into microbial
prophylaxis also remained high at 96%
and that has been high since we started
collecting these data in
2012 for dialysis centers this is the
first report 18 centers reported
bloodstream infections in 2022 and the
number of overall infections was
considered significantly lower compared
to National
Data hang on for a second I think uh one
of my one of our Representatives wanted
to ask something before sure too pass it
representative Weber go ahead thank you
and thank you for the Indulgence um I
just had a quick question with respect
to ambulatory Centers before we go on
you said there were a couple of centers
that don't report are they required to
report or is this all voluntary
information and if they're not reporting
and supposed to what are we doing about
it that's a good question and that's why
I had this talking point in here so they
are all required every license facility
that is performing those procedures
is required to report under our statute
RSA 151 we have been ongoing trying to
reach out to these facilities and our
program is actively working to try to
engage with these facilities um and it's
and some other centers have also
struggled um some Nursing Home Centers
as well we struggled to uh contact to be
able to have reporting a lot of
anecdotal information when we have
reached out to facilities after we had
some delayed reporting is primarily due
to St transition in Staffing so our team
is making a very concerted effort to
contact all of those facilities mostly
by phone to ensure that we have the
correct reporting contact so we're
making a very um large effort coming
into 2023 to be able to contact those
facilities is it the case that in any
number one being one uh where they don't
report and there's anecdotal evidence
that we get some problems there what do
you do next in the facility if there's
they're concerned about infections in
their facility we we would probably
conduct an infection control assessment
there's certain tools that are
standardized that we can use they're
standardized across the country and we
have also made them more specific to our
New Hampshire setting and our our uh Hai
program has staff that are trained to
conduct these including nursing staff so
we'll go on site and conduct an
infection control assessment try to
understand their gaps um identify their
strengths and be able to provide
recommendations to them thank you yeah
please continue thank you good questions
for dialysis centers 18 reported
bloodstream infections in
2022 um but overall that number was low
there were 379 bloodstream infections
reported in dialysis centers there were
fewer infections observed following
certain dialysis access sites however
certain access sites such as local
access site infections access related
bloodstream infections and Vascular
access site infections they were
significantly higher than expected
Healthcare Personnel influenza
vaccination in those centers was
55.0% which is a slight decrease from
the prior year vaccination coverage
ranged in dialysis centers from 23.3% to
69.5% and for long-term care facilities
for the six report all long-term cares
are required to report Healthcare
Personnel influenza vaccination to DHHS
65 of these settings are long-term cares
reported for the 2022 to 2023 season
Healthcare Personnel influenza
vaccination rate in longterm care was
37.8% a decrease from 58.5% from the
prior season and as remained below the
healthy people 2020 goal of 90% since we
started collecting this information and
the coverage rate from long-term care
ranged from 0% to 100% so there's quite
a range some other program activities
that may answer some of your questions
of how we're addressing infections in
these settings is that our program also
conducts investigations across the
healthc care Spectrum um we conduct
investigations through any outbreaks
that are reported infection control
breaches drug diversion of in injectable
medications and we we also investigate
any antimicrobial resistant pathogens or
organisms that may be concerning to
Public Health we have also helped uh
with other investigations and conducted
seven infection control assessments uh
we are also working on a new
collaborative called project first line
to bring effective infection control
training to Frontline healthcare workers
and this year we provided a train the
trainer program for direct education to
healthcare workers and infe
preventionists we also received a grant
uh to provide infection control
trainings to correction officers and
purchase environmental cleaning
equipment for correction settings in
their healthcare clinics our program is
also working on antimicrobial resistance
activities to try to uh coordinate
Statewide efforts to prevent and detect
it including response plans for certain
drug resistant organisms we also respond
to reports of various antibiotic
resistant organisms one called
carbapenam resistant ENT bacteria ACA
there are family of bacteria that are
resistance to certain types of
antibiotics in 2022 we confirmed
confirmed 67 of those cases and just
this year up to as of November 30th
we've identified
73 uh funding per RSA 150 134 I'm also
required and obligated to report on our
program cost to Health and Human
Services committee our program reporting
operating budget for State fiscal year
2023 was 458,000 the program was awarded
over 381,000 through the epidemiology
laboratory capacity Grant however a
program also was a a supplemental Grant
over 3 years to support other
operational costs therefore no re
therefore due to all receipt of those
federal funds no fees were assessed for
State fiscal year 2023 and we anticipate
not having additional fees over the next
couple years as we have those grants in
one of those grants I do want to note
for long-term care settings we were able
to work with our vendor to provide um
infection control training I think over
60 uh individuals are enrolled for
infection control training so they could
be potentially serve as infection
preventionists in other settings such as
in long-term care and we have over 200
individuals that have signed up through
this training and have committed uh to
working in long-term care type settings
so in this coming year we look forward
to continuing our prevention work and
providing infection prevention training
across the whole Continuum of Care
making our surveillance data and our our
um reports more efficient and also more
consumer friendly educating healthcare
workers and infection prevention and
also hopefully materials for patients as
well through consorti
and then facilitating implementation of
cdc's core elements for stewardship for
preventing antibiotic resistant
organisms and lastly engagement with
those settings that we have struggled
with reporting as um thank you for
asking earlier particularly with
Ambulatory Surgery centers and longterm
care facilities due to transition that
they've had in their Staffing and that's
what I have for you today I'm happy to
Weber thank you and thank you again for
all of that information um sounds to me
like the dialysis centers are are an
area of concern based on the quick
overview that you gave us and I wonder
if there are any specific plans for
dealing uh both with um the infection
rates which are higher than expected and
and also the vaccination rates which
sound to me to be horrendous I mean if I
were uh having that kind of a
vulnerability I don't want to go to a
place that has a
0% vaccination rate there there may be
other people who choose not that but I
wouldn't want
it yeah that's a good question thank you
so we do have these reports that we
publish every year we will inform all
those settings of their rates there's
not only detailed data for our state as
a whole but also for each individual
facility so the purpose of these reports
are for healthare Consumer transparency
so healthare consumers can access these
reports and go to look at infection
rates at those settings so they are able
and willing to do that um but they are
lengthy reports so our program is also
always willing to assist anyone that
wants to look at them we also um can
reach out to those spe specific
facilities and typically do if we see a
very high rate particularly if it's
statistically significantly higher than
what we'd expect for uh for that
particular setting or type of infection
I was just as a followup I think you've
sort of answered this but uh sounds like
the information although public is still
kind of buried and I wondered if there's
any plans to make that more publicly
accessible and more easily searchable by
just person sitting down with their iPad
wanting to know yes and I I really thank
you for that question that has been a
challenge of this program we have over
one one report is over 150 pages long
and that's one of four um our goal is to
make these much more consumer friendly
digestible we have talked about having
some sort of online dashboard but we
also want to make sure there is some
sort of print option for individuals
that may not have access to a computer
or just less familiar with navigating it
or their iPad so we we are still in some
early preliminary conversations about
that within our program and um what we
have for resources for dashboards we do
hope that we can do that over the next
year and hopefully next year or in the
next two years we aren't presenting
these big paper copy reports we have
more of an electronic version we can
point you
to did I hear you say that the infection
rate in New Hampshire hospitals is
significantly lower than the
average um in addition to the great work
of the hospital Association uh what
would you attribute that to no thank you
yes so you did hear me correctly they
are significantly fewer infections based
on National Data so we compare hospitals
with other like hospitals nationally so
that takes into multiple things into
account hospitals work very hard at
reducing their infection rates and our
partners at facilities particularly
infectious preventionists spend a lot of
time analyzing and Reporting these data
to us but also boots on the ground
trying to ensure that prevention
prevention is in place so if there's an
individual that may be on contact
precautions they do rounding to ensure
that those individuals uh remain in care
and protected but also patients around
them don't get that organism um they
also share data with their with their
providers um if there is a specific
level of nuance of data that they can um
do that there's also various measures
put in place to put protect patients in
addition to the ones I shared here
around influenza vaccination but there's
certain um bundles that are often
implemented and many hospitals have
steps built into their electronic
medical record systems to ensure that
those bundles are here to um so for
example central line insertions um in an
ICU they have what is called a clip
bundle to ensure that certain measures
are put in place so patients do not have
a bloodstream infection as a result from
that central line good thank you uh any
questions representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking the question what I
found interesting is that most of the
infections we're talking about through
out this report in bacterial nature yet
the report also is the measurement of a
vaccine for influenza which is a virus
MH so why are we pulling in influenza
for some monitoring capability but most
of the infections we're talking about
are bacterial nature that's an excellent
question thank you so as you mentioned
most of these infections following
surgical sight infections bloodstream
infections they are all bacteria in
nature we also monitor compliance
measures or measures put in place that
can help protect patients and one such
measure is through immunization efforts
to prevent other infectious diseases
from circulating in a healthcare setting
and influenza we have identified
outbreaks in various healthc care
settings of influenza primarily in
nursing home settings um where most
years we do see I don't have the number
off the top of my head how many
outbreaks we have seen in in those
settings but I could always pull that
and get it back to you follow up and
thank you for that so do we I noticed in
the vaccination rates there is a range
so what kind of correlation do we have
with somebody or facility that has a
high vaccination rate does it have a
corresponding low infection rate so I
don't think we could really directly
correlate low vaccination rate to low
infection rate or vice versa but we'd
have to be able to look directly at
influenza activity in that Health Care
Facility so particular relevant to that
we have been wanting to look into a
project to do that we have just not had
the capacity yet to do so we would like
to look at um outbreaks and B setting by
influenza vaccination rate um in in the
future
yeah good thank you thank you so much
and I will leave these copies for you
okay next up tuition waiver for children
in State foster care or
guardianship we did that didn't we it
was at like deja vu all over again okay
that's say that sounds familiar okay
next uh the Hampshire Health Officers
report Wayne Mr Wayne Whitford and Miss
sopia
think good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee could I ask you to be a
little closer to the mic for my aging
ears thank you thank you uh my name is
Wayne Whitford I'm president of the New
Hampshire Health offic Association and
I'm here to at the invitation of the
committee uh to discuss State Readiness
report for health officers the
information as a report was uh which you
should have there uh covers the period
of November 1st 2022 to November 1st
2023 uh State Readiness report uh is
required under RSA 128 col 11 be
submitted annually to the Joint
legislation committee uh by November 1st
of each year uh in the in the early fall
of this year New Hampshire Health
Officers Association uh in conjunction
with the
HHS
uh uh conducted a survey of New
Hampshire Health officers that determine
their Readiness to respond to health
threats uh the result of the survey is
outlined in the Readiness report uh
Readiness to respond to health threats
required understanding of both the
various risks to the Community Health
and the ability to train support Health
officers to address that Health officers
have three primary State Health statutes
to provide them with authority to the
ACT including attend uh sanitation in
RSA 128 housing standards in RSA 48a and
health nuisances in 147 RSA
147 uh the main role of a health officer
is to reduce the spread of environmental
H hazards between populations thus
reducing costs ESS and suffering Health
officers focus on sanitary hazards in
air water waste housing and related
nuisances State of New Hampshire has 217
Health offices and Deputy Health offices
and RSA 128 specifies that a health
officer is appointed for each town in
the state most of the health officers
especially in the smaller towns work on
a part-time of volunteer basis uh 22% of
Health officers participate in a 13
Regional public public health networks
throughout the state helping emergency
preparedness and response to health
threats and disease outbreaks as of the
report of October 30th uh 20 33 towns
have filed voluntary Community Readiness
reports New Hampshire Health office
Association conducts full day training
workshops for health offices in the
spring of and fall of each year an
example of training to topics are
hoarding squala peptic issues and
farming concerned in addition to the
semiannual Workshops the Health offic
Association provides information and
support to the state's local Health
officers throughout the year stealth the
association also participates with the
Department of Public Health Services in
Regional Health uh Network training in
the past year Health offices have
accomplished in the following resolving
hooding situations and connecting
residents with the appropriate resources
working with property owners to bring
fail septic systems into compliance
updating Town's Hazard mitigation plans
developing local tools to assist Food
Service inspections increasing local
awareness of araro
concerns offices of the New Hampshire
Health offices are waynewood President
uh Brian loide vice president Heidi PE
secretary and Dennis uh
Treasurer uh Public Health threats that
have been identified through the survey
housing issues s unsanitary living
conditions hoarding mental health
conditions homelessness and mold
possible solutions inre increase
cooporation with NHA and DHHS EXC excuse
me um I'm reading along with you so
you're reading your report correct
basically could you just give us a quick
summary and let us ask questions because
I'm going to take this home and read it
tonight more slowly certain okay okay uh
the health threats are including healing
issues uh septic systems compliance
nuisances and lack of adequate Staffing
time and
funding and we thank you for uh inviting
us and I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative
Weber thank you very much for this thank
you for coming today that's a wealth of
information I'm in trying to digest the
numbers on page one um I see the total
health officers is two
27 uh that means that there are some
towns obviously that don't have health
officers of any sort and I'm wondering
of the
2117 um are you counting only one Health
officer for example in Manchester I'm
trying to get a sense of the number of
towns that have no Health officers or
coverage if you have that information
you may not have it sliced and diced
that way okay there are a number of town
that do not have that do have vacancies
for a number of reasons such as
retirements and so forth uh by by
Statute uh if there is not an appointed
Health officer the board of Selectmen uh
act as health offic for that town so
that is in place although there's not
someone who has been appointed do you
have information on the uh
number hi committee um my name is Sophia
Johnson and I'm the administrator for
the health officer liaison program at
the Department of Public Health Services
and our program is responsible for
tracking um the number of Health
officers at any given time as well as
engaging that appointment process um so
it's interesting in that New Hampshire
towns are required to have a health
officer and that Health officer is
appointed by the state um New Hampshire
cities such as Manchester um do not have
to be appointed by the state they are
responsible for appointing their own
health officer so while we support them
we don't necessarily include them in our
counting um the total that you see here
2117 is the one Health officer per Town
um and then under that number there are
94 additional deputies so towns can have
an additional Health officer if they so
choose um but right now um we have about
a 12% vacancy rate um and unfortunately
um the towns from what I'm hearing it's
that it can be very hard to identify
somebody to serve in this town because
of the skill set it's a very vast um
knowledge that you need to serve in this
town so they often times don't have the
budget to bring in that person to fill
that role um uh yeah but at at any given
time you know we can provide you those
numbers follow up thank you our Our Town
vet has been our health officer for I
think probably centuries at this point
it's been a whole series of them but
thank you very much for that
clarification because that was exactly
what I needed to know does the health
officer have to live in the town that's
a great question um they do not um so
there are situations where one Health
officer let's say living in Pittsfield
can serve for the surrounding towns so
we have health officers who serve for
multiple communities yeah so that makes
it easier if a small town doesn't have
one they may be able to join in with
someone else yes and we provide um my
program provides that guidance to towns
so we help towns um navigate what
options there are for bringing in a
health officer representative
Merchant thank you Mr
are there any counties in New Hampshire
that backfill the communities with
health officer based upon the skill set
we're talking about difficult in finding
it and finding someone at the county
level that the towns can share
collectively is there any counties out
there doing it so currently there's no
model like that and that's something
that we are exploring and we're working
with the regional public health networks
to see is there an opportunity to employ
a health officer at the regional level
again something that's not happening as
of right now now but we're certainly
looking into that um because the towns
don't have the the Personnel or the
funding to support this position in many
situations and what we find is that the
town elects the fire chief or somebody
from the police department um and so
then our programs are tasked with
bringing that person up to speed and the
knowledge that they need to serve in
that position
with Senator gray I if you're going to
do that you may want to get with Mr
Williams because there is leg ation
requested by the department to talk
about how they are appointed and that
legislation could be modified with your
suggestions should you be quick enough
that we can do that thank you for that
yeah thank you so much I'm going to take
this home and plow through it thank you
thank you
good chair now recognizes uh oh my gosh
speaking of the Hospital Association
Paula minahan and Ben Bradley would you
up and I have a f first I have a
question for Mr Bradley what's your
middle
name hi Mr chair uh Benjamin Clark
Bradley it's not crown and shield is it
no it is not you know who Benjamin crown
and shield Bradley is do you I think I
do yeah Pentagon Papers Washington Post
I had to get that clear sir you're not
the third or anything no that's uh
that's E versus ey which is uh my
spelling oh he had a typo and yet he was
a newspaper guy okay say hi guys thank
you Mr
chair so hello um so I wanted to
introduce um everyone to um to to you to
Ben Bradley um who is the news vice
president of state government relations
at the hospital Association so today is
my last day at the association so um but
Ben has has been with us for a couple
weeks which has been great and we've had
some um good quality time together but I
wanted to introduce him to everyone and
um he can just int explain his
background a little bit I thought that
would be
helpful thanks Paul um you can tell I'm
swimming in my shoes uh but um this is a
friendly question by way of introduction
uh yes Ben Bradley vice president state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association um I may
be a familiar face to you all uh as
formerly working for a New Hampshire
hospital Wentworth Douglas in do New
Hampshire uh which is uh where I've been
for probably about the past seven years
or so uh working closely with the
association Paul and I have gotten to
know each other over probably the last
decade or so um and really look forward
to representing hospitals and working
with and for all of you as well so happy
to take questions we'll share my contact
information and make sure that you're
able to reach me at any time if you need
my help thank you when do you expect to
have your business cards that's a good
question I would I'm going to say check
optim
anyone Mr chairman yes
please I just wanted to be very grateful
to have this opportunity because I
missed several other ones to say thank
you so much to Paula minahan for all she
has done for years and years and years
and um it's been a great Association
I've really appreciated your expertise
and your input and um we will miss you
horribly but wish you all the best going
forward so glad to be able to say that
and into a microphone as well because I
was going to run out after you if you
looked like you were getting up leaving
thank you so much it's been a pleasure
and an honor representing the hospital
it's been a pleasure working with all of
you through the years so can you tell us
where where you're sailing off to um we
are literally sailing off to New Zealand
and Australia for a few weeks um in in
in when you guys start your session I
will be in New Zealand in Australia so
I'll be thinking of
you I'll bring back pictures I'll I'll
I'll come visit
occasionally and I do want to express my
appreciation both chairman of this
committee and in my two years at Health
and Human Services committee and I want
to thank you for keeping infections so
you I just wanted to follow up on
represent Weber uh it's been a pleasure
to work with you throughout the years
both as a legislator and also in the
hospital system before you've been a
tremendous asset to all of us and I wish
you the best in New Zealand and
Australia it sounds like a wonderful
wonderful trip enjoy thank you
Senator I I was just uh wanting to make
sure that we noted that she's going an
awful far to get away from us and find
some warm
weather is that an engineer
joke it's good it's a bit coincidental
but um
yeah interesting I know you guys are
starting your session very ear very
quickly it looks like so it's going to
go long good luck to yeah thank you and
Ben Bradley if you'd say a little bit
more about yourself where were you
native to where did you go to school and
all those fun things do you like dogs
you know all the usuals yes all of the
above thank you Mr chairman um my family
and I live in barington New Hampshire um
and have been there uh since about
2019 uh and I'm a a graduate of St Ansel
College um and uh spent some time in
Washington uh but wanted to return home
to raise a family and uh enjoy the
quality life here in New Hampshire so
what did you do in
Washington I worked for a couple members
of uh the the Senate I worked for uh
Kelly aot when she was a US senator and
okay I've met them
both thank you thank you so much and
unless I missed anything I think that's
it um so thanks all for coming and see
you on the
a.m.